Even if you read through the Bible’s Old
Testament recently, or perhaps aren’t an
overtly religious person to begin with, you
most likely will have still heard the tale
of Noah’s Ark.
Here’s a quick rundown before things get
all anomalous.
God appears to a man named Noah, warning him
that he plans to unleash a flood.
This disaster will engulf the entire Earth,
and allow the world a chance to begin anew,
washed clean for a fresh start.
God tells Noah this as he has appointed him
to carry out a task ahead of the coming flood.
This task was to gather two, a male and female,
of every possible type of animal, and ensure
that the creatures survived the coming flood.
And so, Noah and his family did this, they
rounded up two of every animal from every
species, and two by two they were herded onto
a huge wooden boat: Noah’s Ark.
Now, granted it does seem pretty unfeasible
that one man and his family were able to gather
at least two of every animal in the entire
world.
And yes, there currently exists no scientific
evidence that a simultaneous global flood
is possible, or that the boat described in
the Bible ever actually existed in the first
place.
And lastly, we know what you’re probably
already thinking: Are we about to reveal that
this video’s SCP is the actual Ark that
Noah used to survive the flood?
Or was he maybe gifted some anomalous item
that allowed him to fit all the animals inside
it?
All good guesses, but no, that’s not where
we’re going with this.
We only bring up Noah’s Ark because it’s
the perfect segue into the real topic of today’s
video: SCP-6008.
So, let’s set the stage and turn our focus
away from the time of the Old Testament, to
almost eighty years in our future.
The year is 2100, New Year’s Day, and Planet
Earth is on the brink of destruction.
At this time, SCP-6008 is the designation
given to the ongoing damage being done to
the environment, the threat of rising sea
levels caused by global warming.
It is due to these inevitable disasters that
the SCP Foundation in their wisdom has realized
that a number of their containment facilities
and other sites are at risk of being destroyed
by environmental collapse.
So, to combat this, what do they do?
Use some anomalous technology like SCP-2000
or a powerful, reality-warping entity to reverse
the damage done to the Earth?
No, they naturally start building facilities
in places that are higher up, and less likely
to be ruined by a climate disaster, as this
was a little more practical than taking the
anomalous nuclear option.
Aware of the impending devastation the Foundation
and the world faced, the O5 Council found
themselves holding strategy conferences with
the Ethics Committee as well as O4 Command.
Bear in mind, the O4s are a different team
within the Foundation than the O5 Council.
The Council, as you are probably aware, are
the supreme overseers of the entire organization
with executive power over every facet of its
operation.
Or at least, that’s their role in a nutshell.
They also all happen to be immortal and have
been at the head of the SCP Foundation for
perhaps centuries, but let’s not stray too
far off-topic here.
On the other hand, The O4 Command is almost
like a subdivision, whose function is to declare
and implement the lockdown of Foundation facilities.
If a site is compromised, either by an SCP
breaching containment, or say, by an environmental
disaster, then O4 Command’s job is to declare
a lockdown, call in assistance from another
site, and otherwise carry out the proper security
protocols to handle the occurrence.
The point of their conference was to determine
whether or not the SCP Foundation was within
its rights to use anomalous means to combat
the effects of climate change.
On the one side of the argument, from the
stance of the Ethics Committee, the Foundation
had a duty and responsibility to protect and
safeguard the people of Planet Earth.
Unless they did something, humanity would
be doomed.
The counterpoint was that the Foundation had
no right to interfere and change the fate
of the world on a whim.
Not like they’ve ever done that before,
right?
Ultimately, the O5 Council had the final say
and voted not to employ their anomalous resources
to prevent catastrophe.
According to them, humanity had caused this
themselves and the SCP Foundation had no right
to interfere.
Instead, they focused on protecting the organization
itself.
Their relocation operation commenced in the
latter half of 2100, with all Foundation facilities
in the north-eastern United States placed
in a near-permanent state of high alert.
Twenty four anomalous breaches occurred, and
a total of sixteen Mobile Task Forces were
deployed to either re-contain these SCPs,
or eliminate them.
All the while, with threats from the environment
looming ever closer, the Foundation’s Ethics
Committee was still pushing for something
to be done to help the civilians that would
fall victim to the catastrophe.
They drafted up plans and proposals to assist
some eleven billion refugees, but these were
once again rejected by Overwatch Command.
Instead, their plan hinged on the activation
of SCP-2000, an underground Foundation facility
designed to be used for the reconstruction
of human civilization following an XK-Class
end of the world scenario.
In other words, it’s a human factory, capable
of recreating our entire species in the event
of total global extinction.
This drew the attention of one Ms. D.C. al
Fine, the Undersecretary of the Global Occult
Coalition.
Her intention was to act on behalf of the
GOC to directly intervene in the Foundation’s
plans for the approaching environmental disasters.
However, certain members of the O5 Council
didn’t seem too open about sharing their
strategies, claiming that the Foundation was
doing nothing to prevent the oncoming ecological
apocalypse, nor did they have a contingency
in place.
However, one of the council members, O5-12
otherwise known as Nakeda, approached Ms al
Fine shortly after this meeting.
According to him, there were a number of the
council who shared al Fine’s sentiments,
that the Foundation’s resources could be
used to preserve human life, even if they
could not be seen as preventing the end of
the world.
Nakeda took the opportunity to introduce al
Fine to something known only as the Genesis
Initiative.
Over the course of the next year, mercenaries
working for the GOC attempted to steal a number
of anomalies from the SCP Foundation.
Their hands forced, the O5 Council ordered
the termination of ninety-eight percent of
their contained entities and objects, and
in retaliation, MTF Alpha-1, the Red Right
Hand, was sent to hunt down the GOC leaders.
Among the SCPs destroyed by GOC mercenaries
was SCP-2000, which wasn’t the Foundation’s
secret contingency plan, but the backup in
case Nakeda’s Genesis Initiative failed.
Or as he described it, a restart button for
the entire planet.
Al Fine had ordered SCP-2000s destruction,
hoping it would get the Genesis Initiative
off the ground, forcing the O5 Council to
allow this plan to go forward.
It was a tragedy of errors: Fine believed
that SCP-2000 was only a boot-up system for
the O5 Council, not all of humanity.
Nakeda was unconvinced, claiming that humanity’s
only hope was something he referred to as
Noah.
And as for al Fine?
She went missing during the evacuation of
New York City, never appearing at any refugee
sites, or ever even being spotted by facial
recognition.
Who or what was the ‘Noah’ that Nakeda
had so much faith in?
Well, rather than its Biblical namesake, this
Noah wasn’t a person, but an artificial
intelligence.
An AIC - or Artificially Intelligent Conscript
- for those who are not yet aware, is an advanced
form of artificial intelligence that the Foundation
developed and uses to run its systems.
So, what was the purpose of the Noah AIC?
To protect the last living organisms on Planet
Earth, and complete the final stages of the
Genesis Initiative.
With the destruction of SCP-2000, countless
physical samples of the world’s genetic
history had been lost.
DNA taken from every species of creature and
plant on Earth had been stored at the SCP-2000
facility, and all of them were now destroyed.
However, there did still exist a digital database,
containing the information on all of those
genetic blueprints.
It fell to the Noah AIC to come up with ways
that this data could be used to somehow save
the organisms of Planet Earth.
The goal of the Genesis Initiative became
a race for the solution of how to use this
information about the genetics of every species
to somehow recreate those species after the
world had ended.
Or, to put it more plainly, this artificial
intelligence had to figure out how to 3D print
all life on Earth.
At this point, it had been over one hundred
years since the destruction of SCP-2000.
The damage to the environment was not reversing
as some had hoped, and humanity was on its
last legs.
During a routine life-extension procedure
being carried out by Noah, O5-12, Jonathan
Nakeda was much the same, nearing the end
of his extended lifespan.
At two hundred and forty six, he was tired,
having lived longer than humans were naturally
meant to.
And, perhaps due to cellular degradation over
many decades, or maybe just because he couldn’t
bear to continue, Jonathan passed away, on
September 13th 2204.
Over another hundred years later in 2367,
the Noah AIC was able to reawaken a version
of Nakeda’s consciousness, a construct that
the AIC assembled from memories the Overseer
had scanned into Noah’s database.
The artificial intelligence had hoped to call
on Nakeda’s advice one final time, only
able to maintain the construct for a short
while.
The AIC had come to realize that Earth was
a lost cause, humanity had all but dwindled
into extinction by this point, but Noah had
a plan.
It was able to generate nanoscale assembly
robots, essentially microscopic machines that
could be used to build things.
Noah had activated Jonathan’s consciousness
construct to ask for permission, to divert
all of its processing power into constructing
something that could, potentially, restore
humanity as well as all other life on the
now-dead Earth.
It would take a long, long time to complete,
but perhaps the Genesis Initiative’s goals
were still driving Noah to strive for a solution,
even in the wake of extinction.
When asked by the persistent AIC for permission
in setting its plan in motion, Jonathan answered
from beyond the grave “We're all dead, my
friend.
Do what you think is best.”
So, all of this brings us back to the biggest
unanswered question: what even is SCP-6008?
What does this long, complex story have to
do with the story of Noah’s Ark?
Well, think about it for a moment, both stories
feature a natural disaster that threatens
the entire world, every man, woman, and child.
And Noah’s Ark was intended to preserve
life in the wake of the flood, and that is
the exact purpose of SCP-6008.
It is a database, containing a history of
our entire species.
Not just history, but the future as well.
In fact, SCP-6008 has a digital record of
the genetic heritage of all life on Earth,
every animal, plant, and person.
It is held within a containment vessel appropriately
named Noah’s Ark, as it was built by the
AIC to travel through space towards a safe
haven.
And what exactly was this safe haven?
A planetary system known by the designation
of TOI-178b, otherwise nicknamed ‘Jonathan’s
Hope’, after Jonathan Nakeda, the O5 Council
member who had hoped humanity could be saved.
The journey from Earth to Jonathan’s Hope
was over two hundred light years in distance,
but perhaps salvation would be waiting when
the Ark finally arrived, just like in the
Bible story.
Under the watchful eye of the Noah AIC, SCP-6008
is set to reach its destination in over one
thousand years, when humanity can hopefully
begin again, without repeating the mistakes
that drove them from Earth in the first place.
And hopefully, we can get our act together
down here and stop things from getting worse,
before a future this bleak ever comes to be...
Now go check out “Secret Group that Runs
the World - SCP O5 Council Explained” and
“SCP-2000 - Deus Ex Machina” for more
of the groups and anomalies discussed in this
video!